noon today senator catherine cortez  masto says she is running for a second  term  and i am excited to share with you that  i'm officially launching my campaign for  re-election  she made that announcement in a video on  social media earlier this morning  cortez masto became the first latina to  ever serve in the senate when she was  elected back in 2016.  she tells 8 news now there's simply more  work to do especially around coronavirus  relief  what more needs to be done and i think  that's important um  for all of us to to really understand  that at a federal level  um my goal here has always been to work  on behalf the people of nevada and make  sure that we're bringing that relief  across the state the former state  attorney general has no clear opponent  this early in the race it is not until  november of next year